Oh, blast. Another round
of biscuit Jenga to you.
How come my tower always collapses
and yours just stays there?
Steady hand, even temperament.
Do you know, I can't believe
there's something
you're better at than me.
I know it's weird, isn't it?
Yeah, OK. Look, I need to practise.
You start the show. All right.
Just remember -
steady hand, even temperament.
You'll get there, kid.
Thanks. Welcome to The Great
British Bake Off.
Hang on a minute, is your
tower glued together?
Is that not in the rules?
Oh, I'd run now if I was you.
Paul, start the car!
Sandi's kicking off!
Last time, a new baker's dozen
entered the tent...
Don't panic, don't panic!
..for cake week.
Oh, my days. No, no, it's bending.
Although Helena had a shaky start...
So bad. ..she cast a spell
with her fairy garden.
It's very charming. The depth
of flavour is beautiful.
But it was Michelle...
I think it's wonderful.
..who was crowned Star Baker... Oh!
..and Dan... That's raw. ..who
became the first to leave the tent.
I knew it.
This time, it's Biscuit Week...
Be good. ..with a Signature Bake
which breaks the mould... Ah!
These are so not set. Oh.
..a fiendishly fruity Technical...
Oh, my God. Doesn't look very
appealing, does it?
..and a sculptural Showstopper...
Are all the limbs out?
..which pushes the bakers... No.
..to the limit.
I just don't feel confident
that I can do it now.
Don't. If you get upset, I'll cry.
Honestly, I can't bear it. I can't.
I'm scared about this week.
Biscuit Week is like
the nightmare for everyone.
Had some really strange
dreams last night.
Biscuits that wouldn't work,
chocolate going everywhere,
waking up in, like, cold sweats,
thinking about biscuits.
I don't make a lot of biscuits,
so I practised as much as I could.
My wife's the biscuit freak.
She's put me right. "Bake this,
bake that. Stop moaning."
HE CHUCKLES
Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's biscuit week and time for
your Signature Challenge.
So, today, the judges
would like you to make
12 decorated chocolate biscuit bars.
Now, they must contain at least
one baked biscuit element,
be coated in chocolate,
and beautifully decorated.
This is a real chance for you
to show off your personalities.
Yeah, in biscuit form. Exactly.
Not just biscuit form, biscuits
with little, chocolate coats on.
Ah, what kind? Cagoules. Right.
You've got two and a half hours.
On your marks... ..Get set...
..Bake!
Biscuits.
I love eating biscuits. I'm not
sure about making them.
I make dog biscuits,
and dog biscuits are fine,
because your judges are really
complimentary whatever you make.
Are you boiling?
What do you think? Right.
It's biscuit week, and we're
kicking off with chocolate bars.
Now, the addition of the
chocolate makes it
just that little bit harder.
What I don't want is a whole
lump of chocolate with
a little bit of biscuit in it.
I want to taste the biscuit itself.
If they've said it'll snap,
we will want a snap.
Crumbly, it must be crumbly.
If they say it's going to be
shortbread, we want it really short.
The biscuit has to be perfect.
This all boils down to timing.
Baking the biscuit,
preparing the filling,
cooling that sufficiently before
the chocolate is put on,
cos, if they don't, the whole
thing will collapse.
Good morning, Henry.
Hello, hello, hello. Hi, Henry.
Are you wearing a tie? I am.
You're the only person I've ever
seen in the tent wearing a tie.
I thought, if I'm going out,
I want to go out looking sharp.
You don't look young enough.
You need to look like
you're still at school. I look like
a prepubescent, American schoolboy.
Yeah. OK, tell us all about
your chocolate biscuit.
I'm doing hazelnut shortbread...
OK. ..with a coffee and
cardamom mousse...
Mousse? OK. ..and then
hazelnut caramel.
Wow. I mean, that sounds incredible,
and incredibly difficult.
It tastes lovely.
English student Henry
pays for university life
by playing the organ
at his local church.
MUSIC: I Vow to Thee, My Country
His ambitious six-layer biscuit bars
will also feature
chocolate hazelnuts, popping candy
and a dark, chocolate shell.
The flavours sound absolutely
wonderful. I can't wait.
Quite a sophisticated palate
for such a young nipper.
Sophisticated toddler, yeah.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
Sophisticated toddler.
That's beautiful.
NOEL LAUGHS
SANDI: Sophistication is
also Steph's aim...
Easy, tiger. ..but her key flavour
is not for toddlers.
Coffee. Lots of coffee. Do I sound
like I'm high on it as well?
Oh, that's really nice.
In her spare time,
Steph enjoys Chester's cafe
culture with mum Jane.
No fingers, no fingers, no fingers.
She'll sandwich caramel
between two layers
of coffee-flavoured shortbread,
and, to give her biscuit texture the
edge, she's got a secret weapon.
I'm using semolina
in my biscuit dough.
It makes it nice and short.
Bit of crunch to it.
I like it.
Oh.
This is the recipe that my mum
and my granny use for shortbread.
It should be fail-safe.
I could be kicked out of Scotland
if I do bad shortbread.
It's got your great-granny's
writing.
When Michael visits
his parents in Perthshire,
consulting the family cookbook
isn't their only shared pastime.
His traditional, Scottish
shortbread will be infused
with flavours from his
adopted southern home.
They're based on Stratford gin.
They infuse the gin with
lemon and rosemary.
I was using the gin in the bake,
but it's so strong it stops
everything from setting,
so it's now just going
to be in the icing,
and I'll just have that for when
I feel a bit sad later on.
Michael's not the only baker
turning to the bottle.
I love mojitos. They're my
favourite cocktail.
It's the really sharp acidity of the
limes and the coolness of the mint.
It's sort of balanced out by
the really sweet white chocolate.
That's it, good boy. Vet Rosie takes
to the saddle to relax...
Come on. ..even if it sometimes
becomes a busman's holiday.
HORSE NEIGHS
Although she's leaving out
the rum, balancing the other
strong mojito flavours will be
a delicate operation.
I did do eye surgery on
a horse this week.
What was wrong with the horse's eye?
Cos I've got a bad eye.
He had a worm in his tear duct.
It was so gross. Oh, my goodness.
This is horrific.
This is my life!
Mm, biscuit, anyone?
I'm making millionaire's
shortbread but, yeah,
I wanted to make it a bit different,
cos it tends to be quite sickly.
So I just got some sour cherries
just to, like,
give it some sharpness.
There we go, buddy.
Barman Jamie relaxes between shifts
by jamming with his twin Alex...
Ah. Ooh!
LAUGHTER
..who is backing Jamie's combination
of sour cherries, caramel
and butter-rich crumbly shortbread.
They did break in practice. Cos
they're going in the mould anyway,
it's all going to be coated in
chocolate and held together,
so it's not ideal, but it's not the
end of the world if it does crumble.
With texture as important
as taste...
Just adding ground pistachios.
It is a really nice crumbly biscuit.
..caution is needed
when adding flavours...
I tried it with fresh rosemary,
but it got a bit wetter.
The orange zest gives it
a nice, fruity kick.
..which could have
a dramatic effect...
Oh, why are you cracking? ..on
the bite of their baked biscuit.
Oh, God.
That's matcha powder. I'm making
wicked witch fingers,
and I'm giving them a natural
green colour with the matcha.
She now juggles jewellery making
with being a new mum,
but Helena used to be
a professional poker player.
Ooh, yeah.
She's hoping to play a winning hand
with her severed shortbread digits,
covering them in green-coloured
chocolate for that authentic,
gangrenous touch.
I've tried to tone down the colour
not put you off too much.
I think you should turn it up a bit.
We asked for your personality,
and we're getting it.
Yeah. Witches' fingers. Yeah.
I'm all over this.
What's in there? Dead bees?
I wouldn't put it past myself.
Michelle's planning to enchant
the judges with something
a little more traditional.
I am making Bakewell bars.
I love cherry Bakewell, so it's
something I go to all the time.
A huge rugby fan... Go on, boys.
Go on, boys.
..Michelle's man of the match
is always son Alfie.
Go on, Alf! Well done.
Cherry Bakewell may be her go-to,
but, for this bake,
Michelle's opted for another
fruity flavour.
I've gone with raspberry, because
I've got so much sweet stuff,
I thought that would balance
the flavours a little bit better.
Alice's inspiration comes from
further afield than Bakewell.
I used to live in New Zealand.
It's my favourite place in
the whole wide world,
and they do amazing chocolate and
biscuits and sweets and everything,
so, a combination of, like,
peanut slab, mallow puff,
and hokey pokey, which is what
they call honeycomb.
Globetrotter Alice hits
the high seas in her spare time
as an officer in the Royal Navy
Combined Cadet Force.
Her three-in-one tribute to
Kiwi confectionery will feature
marshmallow and salted
peanut caramel
on a honeycomb-flavoured base.
I'm about to bake my biscuits.
Oh, it's off.
Rookie error, isn't it?
You turn your oven on.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Hopefully it heats up quickly.
Oh, it's so relaxing. Good, isn't
it? It's quite nice, yeah.
Is that Paul's rolling pin? Yeah,
you wait till I've tried
the biscuit cutters on you. The high
sugar content of biscuits means
not only are they quick to bake...
They're in the oven for 15 minutes.
10 minutes, 160.
..but also to burn.
They're going in at 160
for 9 minutes.
Half an hour then...
..see where we're at.
Difficult to know
when they're ready.
I'll just keep an eye when they
start browning on the sides.
It's there now.
Right, make a marshmallow now.
Whatever their filling...
Ah, fudge.
..the judges will
expect the flavour...
That's my jelly. I want to taste
both the lime and the mint.
I want them to get both.
This is coffee and cardamom mousse.
..and texture...
Biggest worry is that not
setting in time.
..to perfectly complement
their biscuit.
Not puffed up a lot, but it'll
still set like a marshmallow,
and Paul can't hear me saying
that so it should be OK.
So now I'm making a nougat.
You have to toast the pistachios.
If you put cold nuts in,
it'll seize up,
so the nuts have to be warm... as
warm as the nougat, really.
Also, it's just nice to
have toasted nuts.
International health advisor David
makes sure every workout
with boyfriend Nick ends in
some carb-loading.
As well as pistachio, David's adding
another nutty flavour to his nougat.
Coconut drops.
These, when I practised with this,
I've not put enough in, so now
I'm just putting way more
than I did last time.
This is my rosehip syrup.
Amelia, too, is risking
a potentially pungent nougat.
I go to Turkey quite a lot for work,
and they have nougat that's got
pistachio and rose.
The rosehip was a good
shout from my mum.
I was going to use, like, rose
water, but then she was like,
"Oh, I've got this!"
And it worked really well.
SANDI: When she's not jetting off
for work, fashion designer Amelia
enjoys a kick-about with friends.
We won! We won, we won, we won!
Her Turkish-inspired nougat
will sit atop a pistachio biscuit.
It still does look a bit soft,
but it's also golden
round the edges,
so I don't want to do it for longer.
Hopefully, once it cools,
it'll firm up.
Praying.
With just seconds separating
underdone and overbaked...
I don't know whether
to take it out or not.
It's just really buttery.
..achieving a batch of identical,
perfectly baked biscuits...
One minute longer.
..is a trial of the bakers'
experience and intuition.
It's looking all right.
I might have gone a bit over, but
I'd prefer that to a soggy biscuit.
I'm going to leave it in
a few more minutes.
All right, Phil. Hello, mate.
You all right? Good. Hello, Phil.
Hello. So, tell us
about your chocolate bars.
This is shortbread with
a white chocolate fudge,
covered in chocolate.
Quite sweet, then?
I like a bit of sweetness.
Lorry driver Phil also takes
to the roads on his day off
as a member of his local
biking club.
All right, chaps? All right.
Have a fairy cake.
Mm.
He's confident his bars'
sweetness will be balanced by
the tangy, orange zest
in his shortbread,
and dried cranberries in his fudge.
Who don't like chocolate?
Who don't like biscuit,
and who don't like... fudge?
SANDI: With most of the bakers'
biscuits cooling...
It's not looking done yet.
..they can turn their
attention to chocolate.
I'm using 70% cocoa solids,
so really quite
a bitter, dark chocolate.
I'm just mixing the white chocolate
with green candy melts.
Anything witchy, I love to make.
MICHELLE: I am painting
the inside of my moulds.
I've tried pouring it in, but it
didn't seem to set very well.
There's a lot of chocolate in here.
More than I need.
Just want to get a good,
thick layer.
Perfectionist Priya enjoys
pushing herself,
and not just in the Pilates studio.
Oh, I'm jelly now.
As well as making
cardamom shortbread
and barfi, an Indian milk sweet,
she's experimenting with
a brand-new kind of chocolate.
This is Ruby chocolate.
A Ruby what, sorry?
Ruby chocolate.
It's derived from a specific
type of cocoa bean.
It's slightly tangy, works really
nice with the flavours
I was trying to achieve.
It'll be interesting to see
how the cardamom works with that.
Yeah. But good luck. Thank you.
So, I am now going to assemble.
It's now just getting
everything in the moulds.
I just hope they all come together.
I'm not doing moulds so I've
just made, like, a traybake
and then I'm going to chop it up.
My nougat and my biscuits
are still a bit soft.
Need to get 'em in
the freezer ASAP Rocky.
Every minute the bakers
spend assembling
means less time for their biscuit
bars to chill and set...
The marshmallow is a bit soft. Ooh.
..increasing the risk they'll
serve up a molten mess.
I'm going to pour the caramel in.
I need to cool it down, cos,
if it goes into the chocolate
like that, I think it'd melt it.
Little bit worried about time,
but just gotta wait.
This is the mousse.
Ah, why is it that soft?
Oh, dear. My nougat.
It's getting stickier and stickier.
I'm trying to smooth off the edges.
It's a desperate move. Phew.
Bakers, you have half an hour.
Just half an hour.
Cracking on. Half an hour? BLEEP.
I am cutting up my barfi layer,
then I'll be able to assemble.
Just chucking chocolate on. Oh!
God's sake!
That's as nicely as I can
feather, so going with.
I've just got to let it set,
pray that they actually
come out the mould.
Right, freezer. Freezer,
freezer, freezer. Oh.
How long do we have?
Bakers, only 15 minutes left.
15.
They're not very set,
but they're set enough.
My shortbreads,
they're falling apart.
Just praying it comes out.
I'm panicking already.
Just please come out.
Oh.
They've at least got one
biscuit bar.
Oh.
They've all come out.
I'm not sure how.
I'm amazed.
Up against it. Get up,
get up, get up, get up.
They could've done with a bit
more in the freezer.
They're a little bit not-solid.
I've put some food colouring just to
be able to splash it a bit.
I just like things to look
quite pretty.
Does that look like blood? Yeah.
Try and be neat with these.
Ah!
OK, I've got spares. It's fine,
it's fine. I've got spares.
Oh, God.
JAMIE: They're not frozen enough.
Oh, look at that.
Jamie, what can I do?
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Do you want me to help
decorate? Yeah.
Oh. These are so not set.
If anybody wants to help...!
Oh.
Oh, my God, you guys.
You're fine, you're fine.
What do we need to do? Oh, my days,
this so embarrassing.
Are they OK like that? Don't be
embarrassed. Just get them out
as quick as you can.
Jelly, jelly, jelly, jelly.
Wait is there... how many are there?
One, two, three, four, five.
11, 11. You're missing one, you're
missing one! Quick, quick, quick.
Just do... just put it. All right,
my lovelies! Time is up.
Oh, thank you so much.
Please place your signature bakes
at the end of your benches.
Oh.
Nobody's listening. No.
Oh, what a dog's dinner that is.
Oh, Michelle, yours look fit.
Yes! Michelle!
Hey, you haven't tasted them yet.
You haven't tasted them yet.
Oh, God. I'm dreading judging.
The bakers' chocolate biscuit bars
will now be judged by Prue and Paul.
Hi.
Hi, Michelle. Hi.
Well, I have to say,
they look exquisite.
Thank you. They really do.
I love that splash of colour.
And they're all identical,
as well, which I like.
Definitely taste like Bakewell.
First thing you get is almond.
And the biscuit texture
is very, very good.
The temptation to eat the second
mouthful is impossible.
Thank you. Very good.
They are unique, I've never
had anything like it before.
I think they're exceptional.
Well done. Thank you.
Unique!
Rough and ready, aren't we?
Rustic.
I don't think
that's cooked properly.
Oh. Your biscuit could have done
with a little bit more baking.
Feels like a paste.
OK. It does, yeah.
But the nougat's delicious.
Thank you. Thank you.
They look really neat, actually.
They've got a beautiful shine
on that chocolate.
So the mousse is right around the...
The mousse is round the chocolate.
They need a little bit
longer to settle.
I think the flavours are beautiful.
That cardamom really lifts it up.
So ambitious to do six layers.
You really have pulled it off.
It's just that the mousse
hasn't set. Yeah.
They look a bit messy on the side.
Yeah, the nougat
kind of sloughed out of it.
It didn't really work as well.
Sorry. Sloughed? Sloughed?
Like when you've got a sloughy
wound, all the pus coming out.
Yeah, just like that.
It was kind of doing that.
Thank you.
I like the blend of the nougat
with the bitter chocolate.
And you do get
that coconut, as well.
It just looks a bit messy.
Yeah. Well slacked and sloughed.
I mean, they look quite chunky,
don't they?
But they look neat.
The textures are good,
except for the marshmallow.
The marshmallow's not quite right.
Not quite set. Yeah.
I love the lemony middle.
I think that's genius.
The lemon and the rosemary
come through beautifully.
Marshmallow adds a little bit
of sweetness and the dark chocolate,
that little bit of bitterness.
So you have the perfect blend
of all the flavours.
You all right, darling?
Do you want a chair?
Thanks, Mike. Thank you.
They look fairly neat,
pretty uniform.
I like the idea of this
coffee biscuit.
Oh, no. It's very crumbly.
I put semolina in there.
Ah, that's what it is.
Well, I really like the crumbliness.
I'm less keen on the coffee flavour,
I think it's a bit too strong.
OK.
And they do look a bit messy.
Thank you.
Perhaps they taste better
than they look.
Watch your fingers, Prue.
Remind me what the top is.
It's a fudge.
Certainly a sugar rush.
It's a pleasant flavour.
Right at the end you get
the cranberries,
so you get that little kick
of bitterness.
You need that, because it is sweet.
I just don't think it looks
particularly good.
Take it where you can get it from.
Yeah, I'll take that.
I don't actually want to bite
the end off this finger.
I think she nailed it!
I'm working here, people.
I'm fearing Paul's reaction here.
It's a bit boring.
The biscuit's got that feeling
of being slightly stale.
It's almost got that flavour to me
Maybe you don't like the flavour
of matcha.
I understand. It's like Marmite.
But they are very original.
Thank you.
They look absolutely identical.
They are really nicely made.
All right, so let's have a look
inside, shall we?
Hm, very nice, hokey cokey flavour.
It tastes delicious because
you've got so many textures
going on, including the honeycomb.
The peanut is fantastic.
I think you've done really well.
Thank you. Well done, Alice.
Yeah, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Excellent. Thank you.
I wanted something more, even if
you'd spun white chocolate
on it or done some effect.
You struggled with the time,
didn't you?
Yes.
This is going to be the first time
I've eaten ruby chocolate.
The chocolate's got a nice kick
to it, but it's too thick.
The biscuit inside,
I'm not getting any flavours.
Because what's happening is the
chocolate's overtaking everything.
Thank you.
It could have been worse.
What happened?
I put the caramel in too hot.
It's like biscuits
after an earthquake.
Yeah.
Jamie, that's an awful lot
of caramel.
It's pretty sickly.
I can't really identify
more flavours.
I wish I could say that it looks
dreadful and tastes fantastic but...
Looks great as well.
Funnily not.
Thank you. Thank you.
They look absolutely magnificent.
Beautifully feathered.
I love that.
It's not too sweet.
I think the balance between the lime
and the mint is perfect.
The biscuits are beautiful.
And this is a biscuit bar,
we're really focusing
on the biscuits, it's Biscuit Week.
And your biscuits are beautiful.
I think it's delicious.
Thank you. Thanks. Very good.
Well done, that was good.
They loved my flavours.
They loved my flavours!
Really happy! Really, really.
How dare he, how dare he!
The thing is, matcha is a difficult
flavour to sell.
I was hoping the flavour would be
better than the look.
Unfortunately,
it was probably worse.
Really, really happy.
They've gone the best that
they've ever gone, as well.
So, yeah, it's just the miracle
of the tent.
While the bakers could practise
their chocolate biscuit bars,
their next challenge
is a complete mystery.
Bakers, welcome to everybody's
favourite part of the day.
Yay, the Technical Challenge!
That shot in the gingham covered
baking dark.
Today's Technical Challenge
has been set for you by
the delightful Paul.
Paul, any words of wisdom?
These were a favourite of my dad's -
but remember to be accurate
and neat.
There we go.
Don't know if anyone knows
Paul's dad at all?
OK, as ever, the Technical will be
judged blind.
We're going to have ask these two
pretties to leave the tent.
Off you pop.
Bye. OK.
Where are they going?
Prue is crimping
Paul's hair for the judges.
He likes to look nice.
It's worth the effort.
For your Technical Challenge, Paul
would like you to make 12 fig rolls.
Controversial,
I can hear you thinking.
Are they biscuits or are they cakes?
Yeah, I can feel a court case
coming on.
Your fig rolls must use a soft
biscuit dough and be filled
with a lightly spiced fig filling.
There's something else...
Identical in shape and size.
They need to be identical
in shape and size.
It's a given at this point.
Who knew, who knew?
But you have just 90 minutes.
On your marks... Get set... Bake!
The bakers have only
an hour and a half,
and Paul's pared down recipe...
Oh, my God.
..to create 12 perfect fig rolls.
I've never even eaten a fig roll.
It's just about getting the right
texture, the right taste, obviously,
if it's Paul's dad's favourite,
then they've got to taste amazing.
I got the worst comments
this morning.
I want to try and redeem myself
a bit.
What could go wrong?
So, Mr Hollywood, fig rolls?
That's a bit of a simple
challenge, isn't it?
It's not as easy
as they probably think.
There's several areas
where they could fall down.
One is the actual biscuit
dough on the outside.
Which is quite cakey, isn't it?
It is very soft, very crumbly.
If it's too crumbly, the whole thing
will fall to pieces.
Two, it's about the accuracy
of how you cut it so they all look
exactly the same.
And then three, the temptation
is to overbake these and try
and put a strong colour on.
Very nice, pale biscuit colours.
It is.
Now, the figs are beautifully
balanced with cinnamon,
hint of ginger, that stem ginger
right in the back,
they're delicious.
I remember growing up with my dad,
eating these, watching the wrestling
on a Saturday afternoon.
How many could he eat?
He'd probably go through a packet.
Well, roll on, fig rolls!
Here we go.
Just says using the creaming method,
make the biscuit dough.
Very simple instructions -
This guy sells recipe books, mate!
So, we've got unsalted butter,
muscovado sugar and some
icing sugar for dusting.
I'm a bit confused.
I did a dough with the icing sugar.
I think the muscovado might be
for the figs, but I'm not sure.
In the fridge now for 30 minutes.
What's this?
Figs. Oh, they're figs.
They look delicious, don't they?
Have one.
They don't look like
monkey testicles in any way.
Cook the figs in the sugar and water
until thick and blitz into a paste
with the spices.
How much? He doesn't even say that.
Paul said lightly spiced,
so I'm not going to put loads in.
Adding a tiny bit of spices at
a time.
Because like Paul said
last week, you can always add,
but you can't take away.
I'm thinking a healthy amount,
I think.
Whoops.
I'm going minimal, he said lightly,
light, light, light.
My doubting says that they can't
taste any of the spices.
I don't think I can taste
anything but sweetness.
My dough's had its 30 minutes,
just rolling it out to the rectangle
that I've drawn.
Quite hard to actually roll it out.
It's just, it's so soft, this dough.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
You've got 45 minutes left.
Just looking for one of
Prue's earrings.
So divide the fig filling
down the middle of each strip.
Just going to pipe the filling in,
just to make it neater.
Doesn't look very appealing,
does it?
And then roll.
How do I roll it?
I'm rolling it like a Swiss roll,
cos you know,
I make Swiss rolls
all the time.
It says roll and seal -
they're kind of rolled.
I'm not that confident
in my technique.
There's something not quite right.
Man, they are sticky.
I hope I can pull it back.
Cut each roll into six equal pieces
and transfer
onto a lined baking sheet.
They might be a bit small,
but, oh, well.
Six and six, 12 fig rolls.
Michael, no.
What have I done?
How many? Six.
12. Cut them in half quick.
Cut them in half.
Oh, that was close.
Half an hour of fig roll fun
left, people.
Run a fork along the top of the fig
rolls to decorate with visible lines
and to slightly flatten them.
So I'm just going to do
a light imprint there.
They're not like 100%, are they,
but they're not bad.
Oh, my God, looks perfect,
you should see mine.
Do you know you've got biscuit
in your hair?
I like it like that.
That's kind of... Yeah.
Do you want me to put it back?
It just makes it look
like I've tried.
Just got to bake them now.
The question is, how long
do you bake them for?
I'll just give Paul's dad a ring.
Do you know his number?
I don't think they're going
to take very long.
I might give them 20 minutes,
I'm just going for golden brown.
That's my aim.
I reckon 15 minutes.
I'm egg washing them.
It doesn't say to do,
but we've been given
an extra egg, so...
And it always makes things
look nice.
Be good. Be good.
I don't feel like they're
a car crash, so that's good.
I've looked at them, but I don't
know what I was looking for.
Do you want to play a game?
Everyone always starts
with scissors.
Is that a thing?
Yeah, should've gone with...
OK, ready? OK.
Still went with scissors.
They're beginning to go brown
around the edges.
Speak to the people, Noel.
You have five minutes remaining.
I'm going to take them out.
Only one person's got theirs out
yet, so...
I'm OK.
I think I'm going to take mine out.
Yes, I'm happy.
No, I'm not.
Oh, no, I am.
They look fig rollish to me.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
I thought I didn't have
the right number then.
Eight, nine, ten, 11.
Oh! No.
How did I do that?
I'm in trouble.
Bakers, you have one minute left.
Dust with icing sugar.
I've never dusted things
with such care.
Trying to put similar ones together.
And they are done.
Bakers, that is the end of
your Technical Challenge.
David's look actually identical.
How do yours look so good?
I definitely did 11.
I'm a moron.
Please bring your fig rolls and
place them behind the photograph
of your choice.
I'll swap.
Yours are cute.
Paul and Prue are looking for 12
identical fig rolls with a smooth,
soft biscuit and a filling
which perfectly balances cinnamon,
ginger and fig.
Right, shall we start over here,
then, Prue?
They're a bit... Flat.
And slightly overbaked as well.
Yeah. They actually
taste rather good.
The pastry's nice.
Now, these - not a bad colour.
They look absolutely identical,
don't they.
They do.
The pastry's slightly cakey.
But still crisp.
The flavour's good.
Now, this one looks a nice colour.
Bit small.
Getting the ginger.
It's strong in ginger.
Wow.
Now, this mixture's gone quite
flat, but they are all the same.
The balance is there
with the flavours.
Very nice.
This one's not been mixed properly.
It's broken up. It's overbaked.
Yeah, pastry's quite tough too,
that's because it's been overworked.
This is more like the right shape.
It is nice.
And they're quite nice and full.
Oh, nice pastry.
It's got...
Some ginger in it.
Yeah, and cinnamon.
Just a bit.
Now, this one, some are
flat and some are thin.
It's how they've rolled it up.
And they're not absolutely
the same shape, but they're...
Yeah.
It's the flavours, I'm not getting
the cinnamon or ginger.
Well, these aren't flattened at all.
No, they're not flattened.
But they are very beautiful.
Plenty of filling in it
and they are neat.
I think that's very delicious.
It's got just a hint of cinnamon
and a hint of ginger.
Now, there's an issue here
with the dough itself,
the pastry's very soft and it's
flattened out and this one
actually has only got 11.
You're absolutely right.
The least of their problems!
That is not a fig roll.
I can't believe they've
actually egg washed it.
It's like a sausage roll.
It is like a sausage roll,
but they're very neat.
It's quite tough, that pastry,
isn't it? It is a bit.
These are a little bit flat
and uneven. See how rough it is?
It needed a little bit longer
just folding together.
And a lot of ginger.
Last but not least, again,
this is a problem with the dough,
it's very mottled.
It's not smooth.
That's got a punch with the spice
as well.
Yes, slightly overflavoured.
Yes, it is.
Prue and Paul will now rank
the fig rolls from worst to best.
12th place is this one.
Helena.
You were one short and they were
a fair old disaster.
The person in 11th spot is this one.
You egg washed them -
it's not a sausage roll.
Steph came tenth.
Ninth was Amelia, eighth Michelle.
Priya came seventh.
Henry was sixth, Rosie fifth
and Michael fourth.
In third spot, we have this one.
These were pretty good.
Do you like your fig rolls, Phil?
No.
It's a shame.
You just overbaked them slightly.
But they were nice. Thank you.
And in second place was this one.
David.
They were absolutely perfect,
except they were, funnily enough
for a roll, too round.
And in first spot, Alice.
Well done.
Pastry's nice and smooth,
your filling was good
and it was baked almost perfectly.
What?!
Yeah, I won a Technical!
It's amazing.
I can't believe that.
Never made a fig roll before,
probably won't make them again.
Third?
Yes, I'll take that.
Paul looked like he wanted to kill
whoever put that egg glaze on.
It's not looking good for me.
Today was a bit disappointing,
a bit downheartening,
but start fresh tomorrow,
just throw everything at it.
I know I have to nail
the Showstopper.
if I don't, then I go home.
Just the Showstopper Challenge
remains.
The bakers' last chance
to prove themselves,
before one is crowned Star Baker
and another leaves the tent.
Hello, bakers.
Today, Paul and Prue would like you
to make an edible masterpiece,
in the form of a 3D
biscuit sculpture.
You are going to have
to treat your biscuit dough
like a sculptor
would treat their clay.
You've basically got to be
the Michelangelo of dough.
Wow, really?
I'm rapping information now.
Yeah, OK, loving it.
The judges are going to be looking
for different shapes, textures
and thicknesses of biscuit,
all combined together to make
a stunning 3D biscuit sculpture.
I never tire of saying those words.
You have four hours.
On your marks... Get set...
Bake!
Melt butter, sugar and syrup.
I'm feeling quite nervous,
because I'm worrying
I've bitten off
more than I can chew.
With what's happened
so far this weekend,
it's going to have to be good.
So, it's a little bit more pressure.
I just want to be able
to get through the Showstopper
without having to panic that,
if anything goes wrong, I'm out.
Just not making
things easy for myself.
This is a really jolly challenge.
It's technically difficult
and it's very creative.
You could pretty much make
anything in biscuit.
But they've got to think of
something
that's going to impart flavour
but also be structurally sound.
Would you use a shortbread?
Possibly, if it's strong enough.
I reckon a lot of people
will go for gingerbread
because it's stable, and it actually
tastes good, baked properly.
This is a sculpture,
so, of course, we want it
to look absolutely amazing.
But this is a baking competition.
Frankly, if it doesn't taste good,
I don't care how beautiful it is.
Helena, hello. Hi.
Tell us all about your sculpture.
I'm making a spider
coming out of an egg.
Of course you are. Brilliant.
So delicious,
they make your mouth water.
Helena's chocolate orange
tarantula will scuttle out of
a shortbread egg, flavoured with
lemon zest and Earl Grey tea leaves.
I tried Earl Grey
shortbread years ago,
and I couldn't find a recipe for it.
So, I tried adding tea
just out of the tea bag.
That sounds a good idea.
It's very original.
Steph's animal inspiration
is a little more cuddly.
So my bis-cat is called Ginge.
I've got cats, I haven't
got a ginger cat,
but I would love a ginger cat.
Her bis-cat will have a brandy snap
tail and a spiced shortbread fur.
She'll mould the rest of its
anatomy from her punchy gingerbread.
I love a bit of ginger,
so it's all going in,
and if they don't like it, I do.
Whatever biscuit they've chosen...
Quite a lot of my sculpture
is lemon shortbread.
..it not only needs
to be delicious...
This is cardamom, pistachio,
coconut.
I just like the flavours.
..but also able to support
the impressive sculptures
the judges are expecting.
A lot of biscuit dough.
It needs to be strong, it's not
going to be crumbly at all.
I think my mixer's having a bit
of a hard time at the moment.
And the larger they go, the sturdier
their biscuit will have to be.
I am making a really big chicken.
She's made of a spicy gingerbread,
to reflect her spicy character.
She's the chicken that
survived our fox attack.
So, she's a really tough,
independent woman, that chicken.
Rosie's replica of
her favourite chicken, Legs,
will be made from 212
individual biscuits.
I think I've been really ambitious,
probably over ambitious.
I think I'm doing the most
biscuits and the biggest thing,
so that's obviously making me feel
super relaxed and super confident!
Phil is also creating
a tribute to a cherished pet.
Me and my sister had
a little tortoise called Tina,
but she's no longer with us.
The tortoise - my sister is,
but the tortoise is not.
He'll fashion the dear departed
Tina's shell from a sugar biscuit
covered in Florentines and her head
and legs from brandy snap.
Used to take it for a walk down the
park? Yeah I'd take it for a drag.
On a string?
On a skateboard? Yeah.
How did he die?
I don't know,
possibly old age, yeah.
What did your tortoise die of, Phil?
"Don't know, didn't look into it."
Didn't even bury it,
just put it in a skip.
Michael is adding
to the growing menagerie.
I'm making a Highland cow,
it's called Hamish.
When I was a kid, we used to explore
the Highlands a lot,
cos that's where we lived.
So it's based on my memories
of those when I was wee.
His bovine biscuit sculpture will
feature two types of gingerbread.
Its fur will be
chocolate and orange,
while the head itself
will be more piquant.
The judges might think it's got
a bit too much chilli in it.
I'm adding five teaspoons.
I like it to be a real kick,
I like it to be fiery.
And his is not the only
sculpture packing heat.
I'm making a dragon.
I wanted to make something
my little boys'll find impressive.
The wings of Priya's dragon
will be covered in delicate
langue de chat biscuits,
while its brandy snap flames stand
ready to ward off any rivals.
Michelle is doing a dragon too.
Star Baker Michelle.
No pressure, no pressure at all.
Priya's is probably going
to be way better than mine.
Just hope I manage to finish
it on time.
For her dragon, Michelle's going all
out for the four types of biscuit,
including a cardamom and pistachio
neck and gingerbread wings.
Well, obviously, I am Welsh,
so I have to go with
Dewi, y Ddraig Gymraeg,
which is the Welsh Dragon.
It's also the emblem of the rugby
team that I support, the Scarlets,
so I'm doing it for Wales today.
I'm lining my tin
with a gingerbread.
This is the body of the chicken.
This is either the top or bottom
half, they're interchangeable.
These are my wings.
Getting their larger
building blocks in the oven
as quickly as possible is vital.
This is going to be
the head of Ginger.
Might have gone a bit thin on this.
I am cutting out hair-shaped bits
of chocolate orange dough,
so it bakes onto the gingerbread.
It's sort of a Cubist cow.
In. Be kind!
The longer they take,
the less time the bakers
will have for their equally
essential smaller biscuits.
I'm the modelling the spider
by hand.
They're beautiful creatures.
I've piped my combs, wattles,
feet and a beak.
All the essentials for a chicken.
And then I'll get going
on all the feather ones.
Time pressure is really on now.
Good morning, Henry. Hello, Henry.
Hi, darling. This looks interesting.
Right, biscuit sculpture,
what are you doing?
Yes, I'm making an organ.
Kidney? Heart? Lung?
The church one. Oh, right. Ah, OK.
That wasn't specific enough.
Henry's pulling out all
the stops with his organ,
adorning its gingerbread body
with edible stained glass windows
and towering brandy snap pipes.
How big's your organ
going to be, Henry?
Well...
Probably about, sort of
the size of this baking sheet
and then about that tall.
That's the plan.
I'm going to have
to take Paul away now.
Please take him away... If that's
OK. ..please. Thanks, Henry.
Jamie's also looking to strike
a chord with his sculpture.
I'm making a guitar,
because I play the guitar.
This is just like the various parts,
I don't even know what it's called,
but it's the bit that
the strings go into.
The bridge, neck, back
and sides of his guitar
will be made from
chocolate gingerbread.
While for the top,
he's revisiting a biscuit
from yesterday's
Signature Challenge.
This is lemon shortbread.
It's actually a different shortbread
recipe so,
hopefully it will go a bit better.
Everyone else seems to be
sophisticated
and has all these
fancy stencil things,
I've got some
recycled paper from work.
So I'm making flowers.
They're going to look like flowers
from like another planet.
David not only wants his
extraterrestrial blooms
to look stellar, but the taste
to be out of this world.
Flavour's the thing
I care about the most.
So, this one is fennel and lime,
then a grapefruit and caraway.
And another one cardamom and lemon.
Quite citrusy.
Yeah, and the idea is hopefully
to get the citrus first
and then the spice comes through
fragrantly afterwards.
I think if you can pull it off,
it will be brilliant.
This is the sea, sort of
piping waves and stuff.
Trying to recreate when I went
swimming with dolphins as a kid.
As well as a Viennese whirl ocean,
Amelia's seascape will feature three
large waves made from
stacked lemon shortbread.
My main worry is just
running out of time,
so, I'm pressing like 1A, 2A,
etc into the biscuit,
so I know which one's which.
If I take time, making sure
the biscuits are right,
once I come to put together, it'll
all pay off and be a bit easier.
Bakers, you are halfway through,
you have two hours left.
Sorry I'm late.
No, no, you were great. Oh, was I?
I did it! Best I've ever seen you,
yeah. OK.
We're going in.
I'm just waiting for my
gingerbread wings to come out.
Happy, I think.
I still need to make
the brandy stack organ pipes.
With only one oven...
Oof, nonstop!
..it will be a monumental test
of the bakers' skill to achieve
a perfectly uniform bake...
Yeah, happy with that,
going to get the next ones in.
..across multiple batches
of different biscuits.
Are all the limbs out?
The small ones are
a little bit overdone.
The big ones look all right.
What are these, ears? Ears?
They're flippers.
They look like ears.
These are my cardamom biscuits.
I'm going to put them in for
ten minutes and check.
This is Florentines, I've just got
to let them cool a little bit
so I can cut them out
in the shape that I need.
I've absolutely no idea
how many macaroons I'm doing.
I just need to make sure that
I've got enough for all the wool.
I'm continuing with
my New Zealand theme.
So this is going to be
a New Zealand lamb.
Alice's lamb will sit
in a shortbread pen
and sport a luxuriant
coconut macaroon fleece.
Is that more wool over there? Yeah,
I've got loads of... Smaller wool?
Smaller wool. That's wool,
and that's wool in the distance.
Is it just in the distance?
No, it's... It's actually smaller?
Yeah. OK. It's going to be very...
I've never understood perspective.
Aren't you an artist? I'm like
a bumblebee, I can't see depth.
OK.
OK, I'm going to leave it there.
Good luck.
Well, hopefully, this makes sense.
Just one hour remains.
This is my last...
fence building,
this is my coconut lime shortbread.
This is the start of construction.
The risky bit - that collapses,
I might as well walk home.
And breathe!
So, I'm going to make caramel
to stick it together.
The assembly's the worst bit.
I'm terrified about assembling it.
If the glue doesn't work,
this is what I've got.
I'm just going as fast as I can.
And my numbers are helping.
Best thing I've ever done.
Six.
Just going to construct
my little sheep, now.
I actually went to
art school in New Zealand,
and I did sculpture
at art school.
So, hopefully, I can kind of
recreate the skill that I had there.
This is really, really soft,
this gingerbread,
which is not good.
This is the bit
that wraps around the side.
Oh, look at that.
I knew that would happen.
I thought I'd be more
ahead of this than I am.
If things go wrong again,
then I might be stuffed.
I'm going to have to hold the legs,
just until they're stabilised.
Is this staying put? Good girl.
Oh, the organ arises.
OK, too much?
I'll start again.
I'm putting in the second one now.
Nobody move.
Well, I've never said it before,
but I'm loving your organ.
There are the feathers
for the dragon.
Hello, Michelle. Hello.
What are you doing?
This is fire for my dragon's mouth.
I think there's another
dragon in here, isn't there?
Yes, there is another dragon. Are
you annoyed about that? no, I'm not.
I just haven't got the time
to speak. Do you know what?
Yours looks good there.
I've only done wings.
That's all I've managed
to get out at the minute.
Oh, is that what they are?
BLEEP, I've stuck them
on the wrong sides.
Damn!
It looks really messy.
I just don't feel confident
that I can do it now.
Don't. If you get upset,
I'll cry, honestly.
I can't bear it. I can't.
Don't, please don't. Thank you.
OK, cos I'll start crying if
you start crying, I mean it.
Come on, come on, Michael.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have half an hour.
Just half an hour, you can do this.
I can't.
I didn't hear you say, "I can't."
You can. OK. You can.
All right what's next, what's next?
Just about to make the legs,
the head, and the tail
from brandy snap.
This is for the tail of my cat.
Let's colour it darker.
I'm going to start the decoration.
This is coconut and
white chocolate buttercream.
I'm painting dark chocolate
with a little bit of orange zest,
so then I can sprinkle toasted
coconut and make it look like hairs.
This is really important,
this is what sort of makes it
look scaly, my dragon.
Make it stand out in the dark.
Don't want to trip on it, do you,
in the garden?
I don't think these need to be
bright coloured -
classy is sometimes nicer,
isn't it?
Gold star for me.
What are you doing with them?
Stained glass windows.
Oh, beautiful.
Everyone's is looking really good.
I'm making spider web
with spun sugar.
Oh, God...
So, I'm just trying
to make some black icing,
so I can pipe some hair.
Ugh, going cross-eyed!
Bakers, you have one minute left.
One minute.
I'm going to pipe some music notes.
It'll look like an old lady,
which is hilarious.
How long, how long, how long?
Running out of time rather quickly.
Oh, that's never going to stay on
in a million years.
Unless I propped it up with that.
Just the eggs, just the eggs.
Bakers, that is the end of
your time.
Please step away from
your Showstoppers.
Oh, my days.
Done.
I mean, he looks like a sheep.
I'm just glad I finished.
Done.
SANDI: Prue and Paul will now judge
the bakers' biscuit sculptures.
David, would you like to bring
up your Showstopper, please?
Do you want a hand? No, I'm OK.
Not with those guns.
LAUGHTER
It looks beautiful.
The work that you've done with the
shortbread,
I think you've done an amazing job.
And the decoration is so skilful,
it's beautifully done.
Very delicate.
Delicious.
The fennel really works with
the citrus, together,
the twirls are delicious as well.
They snap.
You've thought that through.
I think it's excellent, David.
Well done, darling. Excellent.
I think it looks great.
It is ingenious.
Oof. There's some chilli in there,
isn't there?
In fact, there's a lot of chilli
in there.
I quite like it. It's underbaked,
it's gone really soft.
But the heat that's coming through
is great.
I'm a little disappointed, Henry.
I had this vision of being able
to see all the pipes
soaring up to the heavens. Yeah.
Where's the keyboard?
Er, the... It... The lid's closed.
That's handy.
They're certainly crisp, but they're
a bit too thick.
Pull my teeth out.
I think your flavours are delicious,
but they're a bit too thick, them,
for sure.
You could have done better.
It's a cat version of a gingerbread
house. It's very clever.
Oh, dear. Oh.
It's nice and thin.
It snaps beautifully, good kick
of ginger at the end,
but I think it's slightly overbaked.
OK.
I think it's so clever,
the way you've curved the legs
slightly,
in the way that tortoises get along.
I love you doing a tortoise
impersonation,
that's made my day, that has.
I'd have liked to have seen more
colour on those Florentines.
They need to be in the oven
much longer. It's way underdone.
Yeah. It's a shame.
I was expecting a little bit more
definition on the dolphin.
I can't really make it out.
HE LAUGHS
Amelia, I'm a little disappointed
that you used stacking.
We did say we wanted you to use
dough, as if it was clay.
It's got a nice snap to it.
I think they're baked well, although
it could carry more flavour.
I think it's OK.
Doesn't blow my mind.
Thank you.
WHISPERS: Never mind.
That's highly impressive, Rosie.
It looks incredible.
Just stunning.
With little tuile-style biscuits,
tastes great.
That is such a delicate biscuit,
it's really good.
The gingerbread is very, very soft,
which is a shame.
OK.
It needed a little bit longer
in the oven.
It's fascinating what you've done.
I think, artistically,
it is fantastic.
The whole composition is a triumph.
Thank you. You're a very,
very clever vet.
I think it's astonishing.
It's really elegantly done, and
the piping is exquisite.
I think it's a work of art,
I think it's beautiful.
The colours look lovely.
The langue de chat,
they're disappointing.
They are really tough,
whereas langue de chat
should be very delicate.
The look of it is good,
but how many times have we said
style and substance?
You've got to have both.
I must say, the dragon looks
a little clumsy.
I ran out of time. Yeah.
Remind me of the ingredients?
Pistachio, cardamom,
lemon zest and coconut.
I think that's one of the most
interesting biscuits
I've ever tasted.
Oh, wow. It really is delicious.
It is packed with flavour.
And the texture's beautiful inside.
I think you've done Wales proud.
Oh, thank you.
Looks great. Thank you.
It is a very big sheep
in a very small field,
it's very sweet.
I think the macaroons have done
a fantastic job.
Lovely. They do taste great.
And the white chocolate and
the coconut really come through.
That shortbread is really citrusy
and sharp and lovely.
And it does break down beautifully
in the mouth.
And it's well baked.
And I love the whole sculpture,
because it's funny.
I think that's a fine piece of work.
Thank you so much. Really good.
Well, it's unmistakably a guitar.
It's quite simple.
It's all a little thick and clumsy.
And there's bit too much icing
on there,
and your piping is...
..not the best.
Beautiful biscuit. Oh, thank you.
Delicate, light, lovely,
lemon flavour coming through.
That biscuit is so delicious.
Decoration's not bad,
I quite like the colour,
it's just a little bit clumsy. Yeah.
I think you could have done better.
Yeah.
I think that is the most
sculptural piece.
Artistically, it's superb.
The spider looks very impressive.
The Earl Grey is interesting.
The leaves in the shortbread,
I'd have never have thought of that.
But it actually works.
I think I have to eat a bit
of the spider, too, now.
That works beautifully as well.
It's nice and bitter.
Very interesting.
You can have it, Noel.
Your friend, are you happy now?
SANDI: It was crawling
towards you, anyway.
Overall, I think you've done
an amazing job.
You've obviously got a massive
artistic flair.
It's magical. Oh, thank you, Paul.
That's really cool.
Absolutely amazing.
I should be euphoric,
I'm still worried.
Getting sweaty palms again.
Yeah, I was really happy with
the comments of the shortbread.
I could have probably done better,
but it's just the pressure
of the tent.
I don't think they see me
at my best.
But it's out of my hands now.
The comments from the judges
were disappointing.
I could be in danger.
Well, there's always a chance
that two of us can go,
but I hope it's not today.
Cos then there's more of
a chance that it'll be me!
It's decision time
for Paul and Prue.
Who will be the Star Baker
and who will leave the tent?
Here's something I never
thought I'd say -
what about that chicken?
Wasn't it amazing?
It was fantastic. Powerful.
Rosie's doing well, actually.
I think overall, there's some people
that really excelled.
David did well. I thought his
Showstopper was amazing.
Those flowers. It was exquisite.
And Alice.
Alice, she made me laugh so much,
it was such a sweet sheep.
But really well baked.
So, they're in line for Star Baker.
I thought Helena coming into
this challenge was in a little
bit of trouble.
But that spider, unbelievable.
But that is what can happen
in the Showstopper, isn't it?
Just bump them straight up. Yeah.
It feels as though
Amelia's in some trouble.
I think Amelia struggled.
Biscuits - not her thing.
And Jamie. He's 11th in Technical
and bad in Signatures.
His Showstopper tasted delicious,
but quite clumsy looking.
I think either one
of those... could go.
Or two? Or two.
Or two.
Could we go? Yeah, absolutely. OK.
Well done, bakers,
that is week two in the bag.
Many congratulations.
Now, I do not think it is going
to be a surprise to anybody
when I announce
who is the Star Baker.
It is somebody who pretty much
nailed in first place
every single one
of the three challenges.
This week's Star Baker is Alice.
That leaves me with the horrible job
of announcing who's leaving us.
And the person who's
leaving us this week is...
..Jamie.
Sorry, mate.
It's all right.
I think sort of mixed emotions.
Like, obviously, I'm a bit gutted.
But I'm also, like, proud of myself
for what I've done.
And you don't get in the tent
unless you're a good baker.
Don't stop.
It's just a great experience.
That's why you just
don't want it to end.
I'm just mainly going
to miss everyone, so...
What a bittersweet moment.
I'm absolutely devastated for Jamie.
Obviously, I'm relieved
that it's not me.
Through to next week,
that's a relief, definitely.
I'm just really determined
to prove it to myself that
I'm good enough to be here.
Alice, well done, mate, you
deserved it. You did really well.
I can't believe it, I can't believe
I'm the Star Baker.
Thank you so much.
Well done, you deserve it.
Thank you.
I'm so happy, just over the moon.
Hi, it's me.
ON PHONE: Hello, darling.
How'd you do? How did it go?
I got Star Baker.
Oh, wow! Wow, wow, wow!
You're on speakerphone, by the way!
Yes. Oh, my God!
Next time, it's Bread Week.
Oh, here he comes. Ah!
The bakers face a Signature...
I'm going in, it's happening.
..which gets them
hot under the collar...
A bit of chilli there, Prue.
Uh-oh!
..a very cheeky
Technical Challenge...
I've got to shake my buns.
Look at 'em rising.
They're like buttocks.
..and a Showstopper
where only the sharpest...
That is an abomination of a giraffe.
..will make the cut.
Be calm, it's fine, it's just bread.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media